hello a minor pillow lehigh becoming a  Hodge we are from Georgia now we are in  use turns and I know that mr. Nick bike  city that's why we start to explore it  bye bye let's go let's go on  I like  nikhil cuts along returns yes it's great  it's going  look at the seats recline in George  enter to hell knows yes this is so  extraordinary  oh it's a historical town hall no this  is a famous freedom cell yes you know  the war which was going on for 30 years  was end with a piece of treatments there  oh look I know it's very important for  German people yes I know  stations time his hands here his head  it was interesting wasn't so interesting  than yes you know I heared that mr. has  lake let's go and check yes  hi mr.  new step by boat was so great  this is the end of our day in history  that is the perfect day unforgettable  knock on this lovely